it's a title track of his latest album
which lubli calls the best record of his
life the soulful singer just started the
first u.s tour in three years he'll be
at new york's madison square garden
tomorrow night michael buble joins us
live and in color in the studio
congratulations and hello to you thank
you very much i'm saying congratulations
because as we sit here your lovely wife
is the baby's due on friday oh man i
know you're going to perform at madison
square tomorrow night tomorrow night get
on a plane and go right to the hospital
but i mean your phone is on right now i
mean this could happen i'm always ready
man i'm always right and it's funny
because i dared complain and say like
babe you know i'm gonna be so tired she
said like my i'm gonna have the baby you
don't need to do nothing
when i first met you there was never a
thought that i would ever have a kid i
know and now you've got four he has four
tony s or tony any advice what's wrong
with you i know tony what's your advice
my advice i don't have any advice really
everyone's on their own adventure but
you're in rare company my friend that's
right but let's talk about your music
for just a second because i've heard you
say you put everything you had in this
record it's the best record best album
you've ever done yeah how can you be the
judge of that shouldn't we be the judge
of that why do you say that this is the
best well i think cause michael
everything you've done is so so good i
think i found like the recipe for it i
think all you have to do
it's really easy to be honest with you i
think if you're an artist
you call sir paul mccartney
willie nelson greg wells bob rock and
you just get the best people in the
whole world and then you sit back and
say go
do your thing and do your thing so you
do a paul mccartney version of uh my
valentine he's the first one to sing it
you son sir paul was the producer
he calls you and he he calls himself
hey this is paul mack he said yeah he
said paul mack and you said i said
i didn't know what to say i answered
he's i said he said oh it's paul mack i
said hi it's mike boobs i didn't know
what else to say
i was really excited though i got really
quiet at the end when when i asked him
to produce and he said yes i got really
quiet and uh he thought he lost me and i
just said like dude
i'm just trying to keep my composure and
be cool but i wasn't good isn't it great
you can still feel that way totally yeah
what is it like to
meet and work with those types of
legends i mean you've met i felt that
way this morning when i sat with you
guys on this couch oh i really do stop
it i was i was lather your workout i
know i'm telling you guys you are sexy
and smart
[Laughter]
klaus over there always says to me you
got the job so you don't you don't need
to do that you're here
there is something i think very special
about this album i love you know i told
you that my favorite song is about baby
out i can wait i will wait
but i love i'll never not love you
because the video was so fantastic
because you and your wife reenact all of
these
iconic love scenes yeah whose idea was
that because i looked at that
you know david foster yeah of course his
daughter amy is the one who wrote
haven't met yet with me and she
had that idea and there's this great
writer michael polk who's an incredible
young writer and
long story you know i think i was just
in a really
good creative space i think i am in a
good creative space i think i'm i'm
happy i think my kids are healthy and i
think it's given me this great
perspective of just
really i mean we were talking about it
before we started just
there's
pure joy in what i do i'm just glad like
when you know when the world world is
tough for everybody i think we've all
gone through a lot of tough stuff the
last couple years and uh you've gone
through tough stuff listen can we just
talk about noah for a second you're your
oldest son noah because he had a rare
form of of of cancer thankfully we're
glad to say he's okay there was a
greatest video posted the other day and
noah is singing
right no is now singing
yeah playing the piano for me there yeah
and my wife is holding the phone bawling
her eyes out he said he helped you right
higher
well he came into the the kids came up
with i mean he was in i was giving the
kids you know shampoo and conditioner in
the shower and he said papi i wrote a
song i said oh yeah he said when you go
low
and i go i say like dude that's a ghoul
huh he did that he did that yeah he kind
of came up when he came up with the hook
listen but i can't say that i have to
say so all my kids wrote that song
so vida and eli you also get credit
because every time in the car if it
plays he said like that's my song that's
my song it's our song too poppy so he's
pro level five going through that and
he's come out on the other side i
remember when you all went through that
you see him come out on it puts
everything in perspective does it not
of course it does yeah and i think you
know what once like we know this once
you go you never stop going through it
yeah i mean yeah yeah it's something
that i think about every day and i think
about when i meet other people and i see
it happening i just um
it's the unthinkable you know yeah it's
you just try to
try to keep good perspective and just
keep your faith and just you know i'm
fine
michael by your voice because the first
time i heard you and then i saw you your
face was so young to have a voice that
is so
classic and so strong how do you
describe it and now your face is so old
um and now you're all coot
i you know it's funny i just uh you look
at it i knew i loved i mean i loved the
music i loved the stuff i loved uh frank
and dean and elvis and all those guys i
love those those baritones and i think
i just always had a real deep passion
for it i think like any good chef yeah i
i didn't just love what i was making i
loved what i was making it for and i
think that's a big part of
why if i'm good at what i do it's
because i really
genuinely
enjoy the connection i enjoy being like
i really that is my happy place and i
try to remind people when i play these
arenas like last night just a few hours
ago i was on stage in nashville the
bridgestone arena
and i said to everybody hey remember
what all of us have been through you
know there was a time here where you
didn't know if we were getting out again
you don't know if we're going to be you
know off those zoom calls we're doing
everything alone and look at we're
together let's take advantage of it and
party yeah yeah
experience wisdom two days is a big
birthday for nate your fellow canadian
calgary-born april yes on friday happy
birthday thank you
got a cake over here
thank you